le temps est préoccupé pour l'alliance
atlantique est la russie est trop
influente dans l'arctique
l'otan est présente dans l'arctique et
dans le cadre de l'expansion de notre
alliance ces dernières années nous y
avons renforcé notre présence nous
comprenons que l'importance stratégique
de l'arctique a augmenté en partie à
cause du réchauffement climatique
parce que la fonte des glaces signifie
une augmentation de la superficie des
eaux neutres et aussi à cause de la
présence russe a cru une inquiétude qui
pourrait être légitime s'il ne
s'agissait pas de territoire russe mais
tout n'est pas si simple de nombreuses
critiques ont émergé à propos du fait
que la russie déploie une activité
militaire dans l'arctique
mais tout le monde sait depuis longtemps
qu'il s'agit de notre territoire de
notre terre nous avons la responsabilité
de veiller à la sécurité de notre
littoral et tout ce que notre pays fait
est absolument légal et légitime
je le souligne encore une fois il ne
s'agit pas d'une zone proche de nous ce
sont nos terres et nos zoo en revanche
lorsque l'otan tentent de justifier son
déploiement dans l'arctique
c'est une situation légèrement
différente et là nous avons des
questions à poser à nos voisins comme la
norvège qui essaie par tous les moyens
de justifier la nécessité de la venue de
l'alliance en arctique au cas où le
temps aurait des projets bellay qu'un
article la russie est bien préparé la
semaine dernière 30 journalistes du
royaume uni des états unis de chine de
france et d'autres pays ont pu visiter
la base militaire russe trèfle arctique
unique au monde à 80 degrés de latitude
nord systèmes de défense aérienne
dispositif anti navires bastion frappant
des cibles à une distance de plus de 300
km l'objectif principal de cette base
militaire et la défense aérienne sur 14
kilomètres carrés 150 militaires peuvent
vivre de manière autonome jusqu'à un an
et demi bien qu'un hiver les
températures peuvent chuter jusqu'à -50
degrés au sommet de l'arc tic des 19 et
20 mai dernier en islande
la russie et les etats unis ont confirmé
leur engagement à maintenir l'arctique
en zone sans conflit le monde ne manque
pas de point chaud alors à quoi bon en
créer un nouveau
dans les glaces du grand nord